let me welcome you very warmly to the
second event of the year for the Yale
seminar in religious studies a gathering
that aims to bring together faculty
graduate students and other
interlocutors to have conversations
about the nature of the study of
religion and the many interesting fields
that that encompasses if you have come
here tonight let me warmly invite you to
also come to our next event I'm sorry
you thought you were signing up for just
one event let me try to bring you here
for the entire rest of our series that's
going to be professor Marcus Lonnie of
Emory University who will be here on
November 30th please check your inboxes
form any further emails under subject at
this point however let me hand this over
to Brazil in toss that who is going to
be introducing our speaker tonight it is
my very great pleasure to introduce
Jessica today professor Boone is
currently associate professor of
Religious Studies at the University of
North Carolina at Chapel Hill
she received her bachelor's from Yale in
1988 her first book the mystical science
of the soul medieval cognition in
Bernardino de Laredos recollection
method was published by the University
of Toronto press in 2012 and she's
currently at work on her second
scholarly monograph Spanish passion Holy
Week in the Castilian religious
imagination 1482 50 and 40 which is
under contract with Palgrave she's the
author of a number you should look it up
a number of articles and book chapters
on topics including late medieval and
early modern mysticism history of
science and medicine effect theory
visions mary ology and angelology she
has told me that her talk today will not
be focusing on this but you may want to
consider talking with her afterward
about the nature and character of
different participants in heavenly
orgies as revealed to her by some of her
well informed medieval sources her talk
today is titled violent grief and the
grief of violence passion spirituality
in
medieval Spain on behalf of the Divinity
School the Department of Religious
Studies the history department and the
Institute of sacred music and also that
this is a personal friendship dating
back some years now it is my very great
pleasure to ask you to join me in
welcoming her back to you thank you so
much it's a delight to be here thank you
for the introduction Lynne thank you for
the invitation and the logistics Maria
and for the logistics Heather and for
including me in the seminar series Katie
you've often who now I can't say there
you are right there you're right in
front of the very bright light that's an
ionized so I will not know any of your
facial expressions which is great if you
will permit me a small venture down
memory lane
I was Saybrook 98 directed studies a
humanities major my sophomore year going
through a version of the sophomore slump
I saw in the blue book back when the
blue book was a book physical object a
course on the history of Christian
thought semester two of for covering
great thinkers of the medieval in
Reformation era halfway through this vid
school course with Marilyn McCord Addams
I decided to attend graduate school in
religious studies throughout my major I
sought out ways to write papers on
religion and in particular became
fascinated by mysticism and it's radical
manipulation of language to express the
idea of an infinite God in finite terms
I wrote a senior thesis on paradox in
the writings of trace of Avila and Jonna
the cross directed by Louie to pray I
went off to grad school particularly
interested in negative theology in
medieval mystical texts I say all this
not just to make clear what an absolute
pleasure it is to be here with you today
to talk about my current work but also
to assure you that it is absolutely not
Yale's fault that I am here with the bad
taste to talk to you about violence
about gore about anti-semitism as
Christian belief in the
Empire again I left deal expecting to a
career in the heavy abstractness of
negative theology it is in fact the
fault of the particular nature of the
first vernacular mystical texts in
Casteel that I'm here now speaking to
you about violence and grief in embodied
spirituality so what I'd like to do is
talk to you first about the subtitle of
my talk passion spirituality and latent
evil Spain specifically to explore the
puzzling case of how imaginative
meditation on the suffering death of
Christ a key note of medieval devotion
throughout Europe including Catalonia
Eastern Spain from the 12th and 13th
centuries on came very belatedly to
Castile the central kingdom of the
Iberian Peninsula in the late 15th
century the surge of interest in pasion
treatises and poems at what would
typically be called the end of the
medieval era corresponding to several
key moments in Castilian religious
history the early decades of the
Inquisition the expulsion of the Jews
the conquest of Granada from the Muslims
and the appointment of Archbishop
Cisneros by the Monarchs Isabel and
Fernando to lead an internal reform of
the Spanish church thus rather than
being a time-honored Christian practice
the advent of passion spirituality at
this late date marked a new stage in
Castilian Christian religious life that
is quite clearly a post con deven sia
ethos in the second part of my talk I
will talk take up my title discussing
violent grief in the Castilian version
of Mary at the foot of the cross and the
grief of violence in the Castilian
version of Jews as tortures during Holy
Week for these broad themes I argue that
it is necessary to examine passion
spirituality and Casteel not just
through the history of emotions as has
been recently proposed for the Latin
tradition but also through medico
theological approaches to pain that
underpin much of medieval thought on
Christology I don't know of any other
scholars putting these approaches
together
and I myself am presenting this analysis
in a talk for the first time so I look
forward to your responses and your
challenges I'm arguing today that the
embodiment of grief the anguish of
physical pain the emotions generated by
defining oneself as Christian to create
one's self as newly Christian turned out
to be the central concern of post 1492
Christianity and Casteel let me start
with how I discovered the problem that
my current project addresses trained as
a medievalist specializing in mysticism
but with particular interest in Spain
due to my undergraduate thesis I chose
to wrote my dissertation and thus first
book on Bernardino de Laredo one of the
founders of recollection mysticism
recollection mysticism or Baconian Thoth
is a three-part method starting with
self-abnegation followed by passion
meditation in culminating in a unitive
stage of transformation into God in
which the powers of the soul normally
focused outwards are we collected in
words to discover a God always already
at the center of the soul Lorado widely
read in The Grapes of Christian medieval
Christian mrs. 'm from the Victorians to
german negative theology to angela
Foligno is best known for a key phrase
of negative theology that inspired trace
of ávila to begin her writing career
no offense are nala not thinking nothing
I spent the first year of my
dissertation Taunton believing the
existing scholarship that I should skip
past Laredo as passion narrative to
focus on the really mystical part of his
text the third stage but there's a
section in part two of his mystical
method in which Laredo after describing
describing Jesus wounds and Mary's grief
voices the spectator as wishing to take
the place of Jesus himself in the midst
of the devotees keening agony and desire
for physical pain like Jesus was
experiencing language begins to break
down and the pronouns shift and morph it
is the soul praying to Jesus yet the
soul is at the same time in the place of
Jesus and the first
person feeling blood running down from
the thorns onto its brow and mixing with
his or her tears calling out to Mary as
its mother watching the bleeding painful
death of her son the breakdown of
concept and language so central to
mysticism and to negative theology is
thus performed in this foundational text
from the first generation of vernacular
mysticism exactly in the part of the
text that was presumed by scholars to be
preliminary for beginners not really
unitive Spanish scholars have claimed
that this part of the text was too
bloody and gory too much about a man's
pain and a woman's grief to be really
real mysticism but reading through it it
was making me catch my breath in the
same way as did the highest poetic
flights of abstract unitive language as
I began to dig around in the texts
available to Laredo I began to realize
that passion spiritual spirituality was
not could not have been a mayor
beginning step in the spiritual
tradition that bloomed
drinka Steel's transition from a
multi-religious medieval era to
monolithic christian empire after the
expulsion of the Jews and the reconquest
of Granada at least half of the new
texts written to instruct new and old
Christians alike and how to be Christian
were focused on the passion centering
the bloody death of Jesus as the primary
focus of meditation and mysticism of
liturgy and ritual
indeed the semana santa processions that
Spain is so famous for began locally in
the 1520's and were normally popular by
the mid 16th century throughout Spain
and its empire but when I tried to
connect the these new vernacular
renditions of passion spirituality post
1492 to medieval Castilian trends there
was no way to do it unlike the rest of
Europe including Catalonia and eastern
Spain medieval Castilians evinced very
little interest and passion centred
devotions so the question is what was
the passion spirituality tradition from
medieval Castilians
to be weary of it anybody who studies
later medieval spirituality is aware
that uses blood in few
the meditations the prayers liturgies
poems drama altar pieces religious
sculptured visionary records and
mystical texts throughout Europe
inspiring not only meditation on Mary's
grief at the foot of the cross and
mystical contemplation of Jesus I'd
wound as a potential plaintiff
penetrated entrance into his body but
also flatulent movements Eucharistic
devotion and anti Judaism most
prominently imaginative meditation on
the life of Christ with particular
interest in his last days from the genre
known as effective piety including many
bestsellers of the later Middle Ages
throughout these Latin treatises and
poetry
not to mention various vernacular works
from across Europe authors expanded the
details of the torture applied to Jesus
body and here is just a quick list of a
few of the top bestsellers they proposed
the devotees these texts proposed that
devotees both male and female should
concentrate on for example the intense
contraction of the nerves in Jesus hands
during the nailing or perhaps as the
Carthusian lootus of sex he suggested
the devotee should considered the
wrenching dislocation of Jesus shoulder
when after one hand was affixed to the
cross the soldiers stretched his body
forcefully to reach his hand to the
other nail hole that had been pre
hammered biblical verses from
lamentations and Jobe justified the
description of Jesus has so injured that
his body seemed leprous wounded from
head to toe the most popular episode in
these best-selling medieval passion
texts was the so called plank dasmariñas
John Revere lamented Mary expanded Jesus
mention of her at the foot of the cross
into a full-throated soliloquy of rage
and grief over the unmerited death of
her son Mary's voice vilified those who
crucified Him and Jesus himself for
abandoning her Mary's lament was so
powerful a model of appropriate
Christian reaction to the crucifixion
that some authors extracted this episode
from the rest
the narrative and circulated it on its
own here Marion was meant to be a model
for Christian diversion Mary's emotional
agony was understood as a compassion a
compassionate response to which
witnessing Jesus physical possio Mary's
grief Jesus wounds while medieval
imitation of Jesus lacerated flesh
produced some of the most infamous
examples of passion spirituality and
here we have a somewhat blurry picture
taken very quickly with my phone earlier
today at the by Nicki exhibit on the
left
it was far more common for devotees to
imitate Mary's weeping and cries here we
see Mary collapsing into the arms of
John as long China's strikes his Lance
into Jesus I'd oppose her head in
analyzing this tradition scholars
typically assume that Mary's mental pain
is easier to imitate than Jesus physical
pain it certainly produces much less
reaction among undergrads for them to
read of a devotee weeping alongside Mary
then it does furry for them to read of
the stigmata of Francis or Catherine of
Siena's choice to swallow the pus of
lepers in order to embrace an illness
that tears the flesh apart and makes a
devotee Christ like in addition to the
lament of Mary an equally popular form
of expanding the Anand events of the
passion centered the attribution of the
violence against Jesus not two Roman
executioner's but two jewish spectators
stereotyping the Jews as vicious the so
called secret passion texts in northern
Europe served to solidify this
anti-semitic stereotype of Jews as so
profoundly violent against Christians in
the first century and thus likely to be
violent against even ritual murderers of
Christians in the present the secret
passion texts presented the Jews not
only as wielding the weapons but also as
weapons themselves for his spectators
they were believed to have mocked him
spat on him struck him and pulled his
beard thus injuring and shaming Jesus
but in Casteel before the end of the
15th century there is no textual or
artistic evidence that passion
spirituality featuring a bloody Jesus a
weeping Mary or violent Jews was
particularly popular in Catalonia and
eastern Spain yes the altarpiece is
focused sorry in Catalonia guess there
were passion texts and altar pieces
featuring gore and violence in every
scene but in Castile the altarpiece is
focused on Mary or on patron saints
rarely including any episodes from Jesus
last days and rarely depicting blood in
terms of Castilian texts there were a
few devotional and theological works
versão wrote a short lament of mary in
the 13th century we find a bit more in
the early 15th century a few Castilian
theological works though more often as a
devotional paradox rather than as a
historical bloody narrative there were
some vituperative sermons by Vincent
Farrar and anti-jewish preacher in the
fourteen 20s perhaps most interestingly
in the fourteen 60s and abbess put
together a devotional book for her
convent with an apparently unique hours
of the nails liturgy in Latin and in
Spanish and which Mary prays to and
about the nails and how they broke open
the flesh of her son however for the
most part in medieval Castilian texts
and popular devotion mary reigned
supreme as a miracle worker from the
13th century on and here i'm thinking
about franciscan Figo's versailles
miracle collection usually as protect
particularly protective of converts but
violence against Jews and Muslims Mary's
miraculous violence included her actions
as an remains not a mere Eman Snyder's
phrase la conquistadora
on the peninsula mary supposedly
intervened by leading battles against
the muslims in the reconquest later she
was understood to provide direct aid to
the conquistadores in the new world our
historian Cynthia Robinson has recently
proposed several reasons for this differ
arguing that the lives of Christ
available in Casteel but for the last
quarter of the 15th century were
translations of the Catalan French sg-
relatively nonviolent life of Christ and
the portions of his book of the Holy
Angels that described Jesus last days
without much attention to his torture
basically wherever you might find a
selection from pseudo Bonaventure
earlier for Saxony excerpted in a
devotion Airy in the rest of medieval
Europe in Casteel the excerpt was from
Jimenez Robinson suggests that humanist
version of the life of Christ allowed
Castilians in a multi-religious era to
emphasize Jesus divinity rather than his
dying humanity an emphasis presumably
more appealing to potential converts in
addition inspired by Shimon s Castilian
devotional attention was primarily
focused on a contemplative Mary moved to
mystical rapture at the foot of the
cross
rather than visualizing Jesus wounded
flesh parts of Robinson's argument have
proved controversial particularly her
suggestion that Islamic mysticism
provided some of the topics Castilian
Christians focused on instead of the
passion such as white for a name of God
yet the fact remains that there is far
more record of medieval Castilian
devotion to a contemplative or a
conquering Mary than to a morning Mary
much less a bloody God but then abruptly
in the last quarter of the 15th century
Castilians
became medieval at least in terms of
embracing the most common trend of
spirituality from across the rest of
Europe in the 1480s diego de san pedro
wrote a poem on the passion for the
court of Queen Isabella of Castile by
fashion through lava one of several
poems and the passion composed for her
court son Pedro's proved to be the most
popular poem of this era into the 16th
century in his description of the
crucifixion son Pedro goes even further
than the medieval Latin tradition Jesus
is not just suffer a dislocation of his
left shoulder while being nailed to the
cross as luta of Saxony suggested but
the ribs in his chest were pulled apart
the cartilage was yanked out the ribs
penetrated his
trails and indeed all the bones of his
body were dislocated diego de sunbather
thus expanded the scene of nailing from
the specific intensity of pierced nerves
or a dislocated shoulder to a torture
that ripped the very bones and entrails
of Jesus apart creating Jesus body as
one entire wound in the mind's eye of
his readers some Pedro's texts presage
an extraordinary surge in the production
dissemination of a Castilian poetic
prose an artistic passion tradition
beginning in the fourteen 80s and 90s
under the Catholic Monarchs Isabel and
Fernando and continuing through the
first decades of the 16th century here
are just a few of these texts in several
genres it gets longer and longer three
of the six most popular books in the
first half of the 16th century come from
these two lists I have up here now
there's no question about international
influence on this shift the importation
of Flemish art and artists helped
inaugurate the Hispano Flemish artistic
style typical of Castile in this era in
the altarpieces
equally important queen isabel and the
reforming Archbishop Cisneros
commissioned the translation and
publication of Italian Latin and Flemish
meditative a mystical texts including
passion meditations by Sudha Bonaventure
native of Saxony however it seems to me
to be a missed opportunity to assume
that this importation process simply
made Casteel just like the rest of
medieval Europe that the Passion
tradition once available two and a half
centuries late with simply more of the
same for one it was a tradition that
once imported was promulgated and
practiced by Castilian Christians
trained to forefront Mary not Jesus by
Castilian Christians who for whom the
purity of blood statutes and the
Inquisition had trained to be
chronically suspicious of both Jews and
converts relatively little scholarship
has been dedicated to the sudden and
drastic popularity of fashioned
spirituality and Casteel aside from a
handful of specific articles
and I've probably written half of those
but monograph Flint's discussions that
address Castilian religious experience
between 1480 and 1540 most often Fock
focus on the Inquisition and its
relationship to crypto Judaism proto
Protestantism or the uniquely Castilian
heresy of the Allan Bravo's all
specifically anti ritual and anti
external forms of spirituality thus all
retreating from path the passions
treatises that were pouring out of the
printing presses to focus on
inquisitorial investigation of conversos
and heretics is to sideline what was in
fact primary to most forms of Castilian
Catholic experience during this era
frequent and minut attention to to use
Elaine Scarry as influential phrase the
body and pain of Jesus we have here
circa 1500 here are some details unlike
any other place in Europe or Passion
spirituality had been popular for
centuries this new Castilian focus on
the gore Jesus death became widespread
at the same time as Castile engagement
with Empire although I can find no
record of any Castilian treatise on
Christology published circa 1500 there
were many from this date that dealt with
acquaint assume of Aquinas Summa
Theologica - - this is the section in
which Aquinas defined human nature a
preoccupation particular to Casteel
because of the pressing question as to
whether the indigenous peoples of the
new world were human or not the
Castilian devotional practices shifted
to privilege in God's humanity in an era
when the humanity of the conquered was
up for debate is I suggest crucial for
understanding the developments in
Spanish Catholic practice and identity
that were exported to Latin America and
profoundly affected Catholic religious
practice throughout the burgeoning
Empire there are many aspects of this
tradition to consider I approached it in
my current book manuscript through the
lenses of embodiment and materiality of
our history in history of science not to
mention the study of meditation
mysticism and visionary experience today
among these various aspects I would like
to consider two principle ones which as
you will recall I am calling violent
grief and the grief of violence in this
era castilian authors reshaped medieval
passion spirituality into what I call
the Castilian passion of to tradition
this new genre narrated the events of
Holy Week by dedicating a full half of
every chapter to mary's reaction and
while doing so imported an expanded
medieval anti-jewish rhetoric
particularly in relation to Mary what I
would like to map out for you is that to
fully understand the elevation of both
Mary and anti-semitism in this passion
of to genre it is necessary to attend
closely to the Medeco theological
construction of pain in the Middle Ages
and how these theories of pain can and
should intersect with analysis based on
the history of emotions and affic theory
to understand the embodiment of grief
and how a literal rendition of embodying
grief helped Castilian authors and
Inquisition spits pain embed
anti-judaism as the heart of
Christianity even as inquisitors sought
out crypto-jews is the task of the rest
of my talk
violent grief grief that ravages
heartbreak our language not to mention
our pop songs repeat over and over again
the embodied nature of emotional
distress and yet this notion is somehow
also deeply foreign to us today mental
distress has given less credence than
physical illness
not to mention fewer health benefits
philosophers still teach their
undergraduate surveys that modernity
began with hurt even dualism presumably
not Yale philosophers of course but in
many places historians of Christianity
frequently presuming body soul dualism
to be at the heart of medieval Christian
thought it is true that contemporary
thinkers can complicate these
assumptions by turning to merleau-ponty
Zen bodied philosophy of perception or
lack of and Johnson's theories of
embodied metaphor that Center bodily
motion is a source of linguistic and
conceptual thought contemporary thinkers
can also draw on effect theories such as
Eve Sedgwick and Brian assuming and
neuroscientist such as Antonio Damasio
to consider precognitive bodily
responses as a source of thought in some
versions of effect theory the hair on
the neck that rises in a scary situation
that sheiks that flesh and shame while
entirely outside the realm of language
nevertheless do their work in the realm
of embodied materiality by shaping the
responses that we later claim as purely
intellectual or rational but the
embodiment of emotion the physical
effects of grief is not just a
postmodern discovery it was also central
to medieval thought particularly about
the definition experience of pain dolor
in the Latin and its subcategory
trista thea sorrow scholars as diverse
as historian of theology donald malgré
and historian of culture Esther Cohen
have argued the fullest expression of
the medieval debate over pain can in
fact be found in the work of scholastic
theologians for whom the reigning
medical definitions of pain were not
sufficiently precise to help them think
through Jesus human nature during his
torture and death
donna trim been ski the historian of
dominican spirituality suggests that the
theological interest
Jesus capacity for pain was sparked by
the rise of effective piety in the 12th
century
so passion spirituality and scholastic
theology are Co constitutive at least on
the issue of suffering what I would like
to add to this discussion today is that
attention to medico theological theories
of pain in the Middle Ages appends some
scholarly presumptions that from it of
medieval devotees Mary's compassion and
grief would have been less horrific and
easier to encompass or imagined than
Jesus bleeding body instead I will
outline how Mary's emotions may well
have hurt her physically as much if not
more than torture her Jesus inversely
Jesus shame in response to Mary's
witnessing of his torture and in
response to the taunts of the Jews may
well have been the most bodily agonizing
thing about his last days despite all
the gore and instruments of torture so I
think sorry I was opposed to leave that
on a blink so he wouldn't have to stare
at the blood that whole time sorry about
that so what were the basics of pain in
the Middle Ages a medieval medicine
Galen and his humoral Theory identified
the body's health as a balance between
the four humors blood phlegm yellow bile
black bile
Galen proposed a two-part definition of
pain first any change to the humoral
balance in the body produced pain second
rupture could produce pain that is pain
occurred when an external object
impacted an organ or organ system we hit
the skin the nerves or even the
gallbladder Valens two-part definition
of pain imbalance or rupture thus
focused entirely on the body it was
widely cited by theologians and known to
the general literate public through its
dissemination in popular encyclopedic
works
now although galenic physicians agreed
that humoral imbalance and bodily
rupture were the two sources of pain
they disagreed on how pain was
experienced this question of where pain
was felt who was a particular interest
to theologians because its answer was
significant to Christology but for them
chooses agony in the garden at the
thought of his death needed as much
explanation
as his capacity for surviving
flagellation I will trace the Scholastic
view of pain using Aquinas as an example
not only because historians and
philosophers regularly turned to his
definitions of pain and the passions but
but also because the overall result of
his work that there was a continuum of
pain reverberating between body and soul
was regularly cited by 15th century
theologians and passion devotees in
Casteel first Aquinas presumed that only
a body can suffer per se
thus aligning his theory with the
medical definition of pain
however he influential II argued that
the soul likewise suffers when the body
does but per accident that is through
the accidents rather than in its
substance thus anything that hurts the
body also hurts the soul radically
different from a body soul dualism and
let me be clear this definition of the
continuum between body and soldiering
pain was not simply at a point of
discussion among a few elite theologians
trained in Christology the very first
passion treatise published in Casteel in
the vernacular after the expulsion of
the Jews was composed by Andres de leeuw
a convert from Judaism in his 1494 work
treasure of the passion he insisted on
the real pain undergone by Jesus in both
soul and body for it is certain that he
had passable flesh and a sensitive power
by which the soul sympathizes with the
injured body for the real wound and the
real feeling of the injuries are the two
things that make real pain thus Jesus
soul hurt sympathetically as a result of
his bodily wounds there is a continuum
between body and soul so what about the
other direction on the continuum can
emotional agony and the soul injure the
body to return to Aquinas he presumed
that the soul is not only the form for
the body but also its source of emotion
anger and shame for example are two such
movers which he calls passions that
cause bodily matter to change one shakes
with anger or flushes with shame effect
crucially these changes in the body
caused by the souls movement then
afflict the soul / accidents as before
producing pain in the stole two steps
after the original fear other passion
since the soul pain only occurs after
multi-step sequence that loops through
the body before it actually impinges on
the soul this might imply that so pain
is tertiary and therefore dilute but
Aquinas actually considered pain in the
soul to be more acute than exteriorly
inflicted bodily pain the things that
hurt the body that rupture it are often
external to it and therefore even more
removed from the soul to which bodily
pain is communicated on the other hand
those emotions which hurt the soul after
being routed through the body are
entirely interior to the body soul unit
and this feedback loop is more proximate
and painful than externally inflicted
pain ultimately not only Aquinas but
also Bonaventure identified pain in the
soul is more severe than bodily pain
in other words unlike medieval
physicians who define pain purely on a
bodily level and for that matter
unlike the mantra which in American
society is foundational to our social
conditioning sticks and stones may break
my bones but words can never hurt me
medieval theologians fully believed that
the emotional response of Jesus to the
taunting Jews or Mary's tears at the
sight of Jesus torture induced bodily
pain in both of them just as much as
wood sticks and stones as wood whips and
thorns and nails I suggest that this
continuum or cycle between body and soul
during moments of agony well known
throughout scholastic thought was taken
very literally by the authors of the
belated Castilian passion treatises and
poems the medieval Latin tradition had
frequently used simians prophecy that
Mary Sola be pierced by a sword to
generate an image of Mary hurt in
parallel to Jesus by her grief and
images of Mary transfixed by as many as
seven swords one for each type of pain
she saw Jesus undergo in his lifetime
became popular in the later Middle Ages
but the Castilian textual tradition goes
even further for example in the late
15th century songbook of Gomez de ferran
he described Mary's heart as attacked
with a knife and a saw commended or
Roman in his fortune a deus couplets on
the passion asserted that Mary's death
was infinitely multiplied in comparison
to Jesus experience if he felt the pain
of 300 deaths she felt it a hundred
thousand times over if he died once over
the course of hours she died three
hundred thousand times an hour
throughout Good Friday and this is in
poetic form these statements the trail
of blood that late medieval and
renaissance devotee is followed for
Jesus is us also one that applied to
marry her heart cried tears of blood
her face was torn open with grief and
her blood as the source of Jesus blood
was worthy of the same type of extended
meditation as his what I'm proposing is
that when these Castilian authors were
presenting Mary as
we torn apart by her grief it was no
metaphor but rather the author's were
claiming that she was manifesting the
second bodily stage of the three steps
sequence by which emotional pain was
experienced it is true that a pietà such
as the one you see on the screen could
have been understood as Mary covered in
Jesus blood from holding him in her arms
but the vernacular texts of the era that
this altarpiece was commissioned
suggested it would been equally possible
for Castilian devotees to see the blood
on Mary's face as her face torn apart
with the grieving process an external
proof of the bodily stage of the souls
sorrow and lament the physical
ramifications of Mary's grief the bodily
stage of soul pain were represented over
and over again in the Castilian passion
of - tradition and the Castilian
recollection mystical text produced
shortly thereafter in these texts we in
fact find Mary's grief so profoundly
embodied that she constantly faints not
only at the foot of the cross as some
medieval European thinkers had imagined
but repeatedly as she follows Jesus
about during his last day on earth and
witnesses his torture for that matter
Francisco de Janerio
author of the 1526 passio Durham
suggested that Mary whom he calls navien
laquifa cava the crucified virgin died
physically when told of Jesus torture
and then her soul went to hug the cross
but I would be remiss if I didn't note
that Fortin Aereo Jesus pain was
likewise most intense when his grieving
mother was present
according to tener EO every single time
Mary encountered Jesus he was wounded
afresh in each instance scenario
repeated the litany of physical wounds
that Mary saw on Jesus body by that
point then adds that Mary's presence was
far worse than any of the particular
wounds at one point scenario asked but
if your pain and your presence was
greater torment to him than that of the
executioner's o pious virgin why don't
you want to see him scenario also
suggested the most disturbing part of
the cruise
fiction is for the devotee to imagine
how terrible his or her sins must be
that Jesus would show himself to his
mother in this way but is to say the
worst part of the crucifixion in the
visualized narrative was not that Jesus
was nailed by the largest of nail for
the tender flesh and nerves of the feet
but rather that Mary had to watch the
nailing and that Jesus had to watch Mary
watch Mary takes center stage as both
the tortured and the torturer when Jesus
asserts you were giving mortal pains to
me and seeing you and I to you and
seeing me you are no less my murderer
than I am yours so I have so far
suggested that the Castilian Passion
tradition especially its passion of to
genre literalizes violent grief for both
Mary and Jesus further that this
tradition represents the fullest
expression of medieval attitudes towards
the experience of pain but what I've not
yet discussed is what this logical
extreme meant for Castilians Bharati
what did this expansion of the
meditation tradition do for Castilian
Christians in this particular moment
after the multi-religious medieval era
had ended for example just two years
after the first edition of tanios
passover doram in 1528 the recollection
mystic francisco de sunnah a source for
Teresa of Avila's
recollection prayer proposed that
devotees could productively meditate on
a Mary crowned with thorns and crucified
the entire passion applied to Mary may
contemplate her crowned with thorns with
hands and feet nailed on her side open
dismembered and full of the same
torments which her son suffered in as
soon as view every gory detail every
extended meditation on Jesus blood could
be applied equally well to meditating on
Mary likewise every meditation on Jesus
mental suffering could also be applied
to his mother because Mary is physically
rent and emotionally torn just like
Jesus so what did such meditations on
the crucifixion of Mary provides for the
devotee imagined fully expanding the
narratives of the passion in these
waise my proposal is that in fact this
expansion of the tradition profoundly
shifted the nature and function of
passion spirituality away from Mary as a
model for compassion to explore this
they'll turn to the field of the history
of emotions the scholar William Reddy
famously has proposed a class of
utterances called a motives in which the
act of uttering certain emotions changes
the emotion
it might intensify it or diminish it
thus articulating an emotion sorry to
say that I am angry could make you
angrier inversely it could calm you down
thus articulating an emotion changes the
experience of this emotion in Sara
McMann less influential work on
effective meditation in the dimension of
medieval compassion she applies these
terms from the history of emotion to the
study of medieval Effect of spirituality
mcnamer proposes that passion texts
provided scripts for the performance of
feeling what she terms intimate scripts
that make devotees of both genders in
the end feel like a woman I feel as Mary
felt in other words the narratives given
in Latin passion treatises were not just
models for how to generate your own
meditation but scripted the process so
carefully that as the meditation was
conducted it began to produce the
feeling it named in this mcnamer
criticizes us some contemporary ethic
theorists who believe the pre cognitive
aspect of effect mean that it is
unwilled uncontrolled that the hair on
the back of our neck arises whether we
like it or not she argues instead that
quote emotions can indeed be willed
faked performed the repetition of
scripted words it is through such
manifest fakery that genre assists the
compassion can be brought into being can
come to be true in other words voicing
Mary's grief can train a devotee into
feeling Mary's grief if we turn to the
belated Castilian passion of two
treatises that take their cue from the
translations of the Latin Passion
tradition the extraordinary increase in
attention to
marius embodied emotions suggests the
limitation in mcmahon Murs influential
theory of intimate scripts the very
graphic nature of Mary's experience of
physical pain due to her mental grief
meant that in Casteel the meditation on
Mary's experience no longer provided
scripts for compassion
unlike medieval meditations on Mary that
bring into being the devotees tears make
the devotees weeping come to be true and
Casteel the emotions cannot be imitative
of Mary unless the Castilian devotee is
meant to faint repeatedly or be
crucified some examples can help us
think this through the anonymous
physicalist myrrh try saying that fast
viscous school is myrrh of 1511 was the
first of the Castilian vernacular
visualizations of the passion of two to
be widely disseminated until its banning
on the index of prohibited books in 1559
it was written for a noblewoman but
seems to draw in spiritual examples for
men and women and a lake in it the often
greatly expanded the medieval trope of
Mary fainting at the foot of the cross
instead proposing that Mary fainted at
least six separate times before reaching
Jerusalem and indeed on her journey she
swooned it really every step she takes
this multiplication of her spoons served
to focus readers on the body of Mary
collapsed into the arms of her friends
were fully prone on the side of the road
Mary was no longer the ideal spectator
at the foot of the cross who functioned
merely as a model whose lament provided
an intimate script for how to grieve
with compassion over Christ's bleeding
flesh instead the reader was directed to
enter the narrative to help support the
prostitute of Mary and get her back on
her feet
in addition Jesus speaks to Mary from
the cross asserting that she should put
I'm not sure if that's enough put all
the anguish of my soul into your heart
being crucified with me so Jesus tells
Mary she is being crucified with him for
the readers of the fiscal is myrrh it
was the visualization of Mary's
physicality
during actual collapse or with her soul
portrayed as crucified through which
marius emotional agony was made a
fundamental element in the history of
salvation for each of the scenes of pain
and torture had two leading roles that
of Jesus and that of Mary rather than
one
Marius us not the compassionate react or
to Jesus pain but equally in pain
swooning and crucified and to return to
Laredo
with which my comments today in my
career began let us consider Laredos
incorporation of the passion of to
tradition into his recollection mystical
texts staged to on the passion Lorado
calls out in the midst of his
imaginative visualization of the
crucifixion speaking first and third
person about both figures and then
seemingly to both Jesus and Mary
together so here is where you're
speaking to both Jesus and Mary together
what more can I say suffering love one
soul in both bodies two bodies and one
set of entrails if there are two sets of
entrails is there more than one heart
one heart in two chests and in two
chests one side one heart and one Lance
one joining of indivisible love that
neither life nor death separated here in
Loretto reflects the absolute equality
between the passion of the son and the
passion of the mother even to the point
of absolute identity soul and body and
trails and chest
each equally injured by suffering in
grief this is not an intimate script to
train the devotee in - imitating Mary's
grief over the passion it is rather a
medical theological description of the
identical violent grief of both mother
and son in which pain cycles so
continuously between body and soul that
there can be no dualism but only a body
and soul in pain I've not yet spoken
about my second quaint the grief of
violence but it follows very closely on
the reefs entering of Mary's violent
experience as the core of the Castilian
Passion tradition it in fact seems to me
impossible to analyze the late medieval
Castilian focus on Jesus wounded body
and on Mary's embodied grief without
considering the political implications
because the violence against her was
both Jesus and Mary was over and over
framed in relation to the Jews a
particular preoccupation of Inquisition
Spain as I mentioned earlier across
medieval Europe except for Casteel
popular texts had detailed the extensive
physical and mental torture supposedly
inflicted on Jesus by the Jews I argued
that when this tradition was integrated
into the Castilian passion of to Mary's
participation in the scenes of Jesus
torture changed from violent grief into
being the focus of the violence struck
down repeatedly by Jews external
violence through bodily rupture is thus
added to her mental agony but I will
suggest that the motion that is crucial
for Mary here is not compassion but
hatred of her fellow Jews in the
interests of time let me present this
topic through a close reading of the
physicalist myrrh given Mary's role in
Castilian spirituality from the 13th
century conquest battles to the new
world conquest as a miracle-worker who
protected converts and punished those
who refused to convert it is not
surprising that when the offer of the
viscous colas were elevated the Virgin's
presence in the text to the level of a
full passion he did so in part by
increasing his discussion of the Jews in
fact the Jews arrived in the second line
of the first chapter they are evil and
by the seventh line they were not only
perverse but also responsible for
persecuting Jesus after the raising of
Lazarus the author then goes on to
describe the torture that Jesus
underwent as the product of Jewish
actions individual Jews participated in
the torture by throwing him to the
ground spitting on him and dragging him
with ropes searching for nails and
drilling the nail holes in addition the
whole crowd of Jews threw rocks and mud
from the side of the road and even from
windows of houses along the route to
Calvary at first glance this continual
Jewish violence seems simply an embrace
of pan-european tropes common in the
late Middle Ages but the crucial
difference in my view is that these
extremes of torture were intensified by
being directed at Mary in fact the
narrator describes her not only as
fainting continuously but also is not
down multiple times by the Jews
specifically not the executioner's or a
generalized crowd for example when Mary
encountered Jesus on the route to
Calvary she fainted away and he tripped
on top of her the author describes the
Jews hurting them both in the process of
separating them by pulling Jesus up by
his hair and beating at Mary to get her
out of the way the blows against Mary
imagined by the author of the fasciculus
more raised three important points first
the author has Jesus articulate the
emotional torment he experiences
witnessing Mary being mistreated by the
Jews leaving the reader to conclude the
Jews may have attacked Mary in order to
torture her son if so in the Jews the
Castilian Passion of two texts clearly
understood that soul pain emotional
agony was torture second the imputation
of Jewish violence directed against Mary
and a passion narrative would have held
great significance in a text written for
a Castilian noblewoman
in the 1510 s as various scholars have
noted during her reign Queen Isabel had
modeled herself on the Virgin Mary in
order to allay masculine anxiety a very
strong female ruler since the Virgin was
a figure who transcended human female
limitations but was nevertheless fully
submissive to a masculine hierarchy and
here we have a regal Mary commissioned
by Isabel but note the angels on the
side of the panel hold the instruments
of the passion after Isabel's death in
1504 however this anxiety dissipated
leaving simply a strong association
between Mary and political power in the
minds of those affected by Christian
Castilian reform in other words in the
fascist coalesced myrrh to lay Mary low
with blows was to strike against a
primary political symbol and thus
intensified the stereotype that Jews
were violent into Jews as treasonous
this would have been a potent shift in
the Castilian context just after the
expulsion of the Jews and during the
Inquisition's pursuit of Judaism
heretics finally and most importantly I
would argue that beyond increasing Jesus
pain
marry injured the author of the fiscal
izmer presented Mary as attacked by Jews
because she was articulating anti-jewish
sentiments outside of Caiaphas house for
example the narrator has Mary call out
to her son grieving that the dogs and
evil ones were injuring him and so the
Jews come out of Caiaphas house and push
her to quiet her down again after the
first trial before Pilate Mary terms the
Jews quote traitors liars faults
ingrates an insane an ignorant nation
unquote and only avoided blows from the
Jews because other people were present
thus according to the author of the
physicalist mur Mary was not only
injured by her grief but also by Jewish
reaction to her anger to her hatred of
Jesus tortures the Jews in other words
the fiscal smo did not present intimate
scripts to aid readers and following
Mary's model of compassion to help them
feel like a woman
rather he provided intimate scripts for
hatred the author presents marry a
Jewish woman is the primary model of her
proper Christian devotion that is at its
core anti-jewish throughout the fiscal
izmer the author provides prayers that
directly addressed the Jews not Jesus
and are full of a duper Asian just as
Mary was and turning in spirit to that
evil people you should say oh hardened
and obstinate Jews persevering in your
malice
tell me evil ones what are the wrongs he
has done you here we are why did you
treat him so dishonorably here the soul
was meant to interact directly with the
imagined Jewish crowd calling them rude
names and true Marion fashioned
elsewhere the author went several steps
further and directed the reader to
imagine being injured by the Jews as
Mary was the reader was meant to imagine
him or herself struck by the rocks the
crowd of Jews through from the windows
of houses bodily rupture the reader was
also meant to experience the agony of
being taunted and shouted at soul pain
in these passages the reader of the
fasciculus myrrh is inserted into the
narrative in the same position as
mery scripted as energetically insulting
the jews and enduring a violent response
in both body and soul in the Castilian
passion of to tradition then Mary deeply
physically blood elite or mented by her
embodied grief was no longer a model for
Christian devotion since she ends up
crucified with Jesus rather than weeping
needing the devotees direct aid to stand
up after fainting in fact her grief was
so physically manifest that she was
unable
on the other hand her anti-jewish
sentiment could be imitated could be
voiced could be scripted and
conveniently for the Christian reader of
the 15 tens the script that brought into
being anti-semitism
and generated the emotions that it names
was precisely what might protect the
Christian reader from inquisitorial
attention thank you
[Applause]
and
so paying bodily pain your pain
provocative there's two things I'd love
to hear you talk about first was and the
first section you've concluded
suggesting that if we paid attention to
the intensity of the production of
passion narratives we might unseat the
hold in social religious history that
conversos and Inquisition have both my
cousins are making it bigger
as far as you're comfortable so I've
been interested in what you want to hear
in your historian self okay uncie if we
went big with this documentary trow that
you're assumed identifying finding how
does then the peninsula different and
its broad you know social history okay
since I learned it largely through the
Inquisition I think you're saying
something I think you're resisting
that's right a second is where you ended
which feels incredibly provocative I
don't I mean the the annoying conversion
I could say is insert your note into you
know Nuremberg anti-judaism er into big
stories of anti-semitism so if we take
this moment how do you want to push and
pull and you don't think I'm never gonna
watch out as what what then happens if
you've so in my line somewhat regen derd
the story of anti-semitism in Europe or
how far do you want to take leaving us
with a very Grievous Carmela soprano
version of where anti-semitism kind of
like that the Dame in the back is the
one are fueling okay thanks for those
great questions and so the first one is
how does this sort of resituated ooh
Spanish history in this time period what
I've been pushing back at in in both of
my projects is the sense that
so what the Inquisition lets you
Inquisition studies that you get at is
all sorts theoretically of local
practices all of which are voiced by
people trying to convince inquisitors
that they were doing the right practices
right but the many of the scholars are
trying to suss out how those accounts
are false but this is actually hidden
crypto Judaism and they will name a
variety of ways that people might
actually be sincere but then they'll
really get their generative work from
what's being hidden what this has
allowed people to overlook is that
Catholicism in this period as a
monolithic thing in Castile is is new it
was always before to be Christian is
essentially to be not Jewish to be not
Muslim these sort of forty years between
the forty sixty years between the 1480s
and 1540s is a time when everything that
had been done in the Middle Ages was
imported wholesale translated
disseminated and people started doing
things and they started doing
extraordinarily innovative things that
should never have been allowed to be
done which is why I can talk about the
crazy parties going on in heaven because
there are visionary records from this
time period that should have been banned
by the Inquisition but were not and
instead bishops and emperors were going
and listening to a woman voicing Jesus
for 13 years talking about the the party
scene up above right I think of this
time as actually a time of great
increase in various forms of internal
and mental prayer but also extreme
increase in various forms of external
ritual uh and that being interested in
crypto-jews and proto Protestants etc is
one element of that but that things are
being done and new in different ways and
the business foot is actually exported
to the new world
has I think then profoundly overlooked
if you look at in so far as I've looked
at a scholarship on Latin America and
they talk about the medieval tradition
they will very often cite some very
wonderful say 13th century German
passion texts they won't cite what
happened
they didn't 10 or 20 years before in
Spain because they see it as all the
same thing what's happening in Casteel
is just more of the same and I don't
think that makes any sense that the
Castilian Christians weren't the same
kind of Christian so I think rethinking
and I rethinking with the most popular
texts it's not like I'm going and
finding things that are incredibly
obscure I'm thinking with the most
fundamental popular culture of the day
in terms of the printed texts so that's
one I think there's a lot to do there in
a lot of different ways the other
question was how does this affect the
study of the anay Judaism and that's a
great question um
the Jen I'm not sure how the gendering
of it affects it I do think we need to
rethink what happens when the kiss
conquistadors go to the New World and
identified the indigenous as Jews I
think if they're rooted in this
traditional that has to be a more
complicated moment than people have
talked about I don't know whether the
texts are there to think about that as a
gendered moment but I think it's a
crucial one especially in so far as you
could render the indigenous as for
example more bodily or more female just
in relation to the civilization yeah yep
puzzling me for years I'm gonna move
forward one century okay just sort of
money I go to die in seventeen and what
Mary reveals to her of course is that
the Mary who speaks to many of the
algorithm mm-hmm doesn't have the two
mystic of body spirit thing if she
bypasses all this well I can see where
she gets it here right but her hurt Mary
prays to God
mm-hmm actually she prays to her son
mm-hmm to ask the Father to allow her
feel every single blow mm-hmm that
Christ suffers so even when she's not
watching but she doesn't see what's
happening she feels yes all of Christ's
and the smaller much larger movements
Mary is co-redemptrix yes of course and
by the 17th century
these are kind of missing from this the
same way but what you ended up with is a
female body mm-hmm redeeming the human
race yes and the way that Mary the
Virgin Mary tells her story of ammonia
the acronym in almost every respect I
mean I love the way to present the fact
that watching each other was another
level but I think that she that her Mary
tells the story seems even worse than
that of Christ it's the female who is
because she actually gave birth to this
great singer herself
mm-hmm Virgin America a higher level and
that is very nice to see
the beginnings of this is a long process
you're welcome laureate agree that is I
think the an ideal example of this one
century later and some pieces seem less
crucial and it might be that in some
ways and I just thought of this now but
that you don't need to have the Jews
hitting Mary in the moment a century in
plus twenty years after the beginning of
the Inquisition right there's the
Inquisition is still there but it is not
in the first generation of Congress from
Judaism um one of the things that I have
that I also argue is that the
contemplative Mary the mystical rapture
at the foot of the cross and does not
leave the tradition it just gets
rendered through her looking at the
agonized body rather than jumping past
it to divinity right so I think that
there are ways that over time the the
tendency than medieval periods sort of
combined and then shift again but
certainly co-redemptrix is a piece of
this even in the medieval passion
spirituality itself yes
yeah
thank you I had a question about what
you were talking about with the these
passions of to be used as a sort of
means for Christians to wrap themselves
in the text and experience the same
passions mm-hmm and I'm wondering if you
could speak to any evidence is there any
evidence or actual reading practices
like were they written is there's a
certain way that the body should be when
you're reading this or what was there
what was those well that's interesting
sphere of perception that we could
mm-hmm that's a great question
the text I know that are more specific
about that are texts about how to pray
how to tell you do not specifically
about passion of two treatises so there
is a sort of pre Protestant reform in
Spain is in the 15th century a local
Franciscan reform that sort of
grassroots and they're trying to
inculcate better religious habits and
they talk about various forms of mental
prayer but also various ways of kneeling
in prayer going from image to image in
the monastery the convent in terms of
reading The Passion of two treatises
specifically would I have as proof that
they were being read besides the
printing history is the ways that that
seems to be affecting the mystical
tradition so visionary treat sermons and
the recollection mystical treatises are
doing more of the passion of to
imagining the soul in the scene watching
the couple of the two passions going on
but those are also their method or if
they're telling other people how to do
this they're not necessarily narrations
of personal experience I don't think I
have the specific kind of data you're
asking for the other piece that uh or I
can tell you that it we know that it has
to have been extraordinarily effective
in some way at least the passion
spirituality I think also the passion of
to more specifically is that from the
1520's on the semana santa processions
start in one city by one person with
indulgence for his family and spread
throughout Spain within 30 years to
being the primary
motive devotion and that is has a very
specific set of external actions in
terms of carrying the floats in terms of
the flagellation that would go on and
who is allowed to enter the
confraternities whether you pay with
money or pay with blood etc
already Jesus and the New Testament says
it would take up your cross follow me to
follow me to knit across what ideas
somehow that you've lost the only
crucified Paul Romans and Galatians
right by yourself with you to died in
the body just as he right so there's
already a call in the earliest sources
to identify with him as the one who dies
and suffers these terrible things so by
having Mary be maybe the earliest the
performer of that and she suffers a blow
and dies with him and the Christian is
in a way than imitating her as they're
being crucified that's a more satisfying
emotionally satisfying character to
imitate because Jesus's response after
all is forgiven me
mm-hmm but these texts you're mentioning
she hates right so you can displace the
reaction which might be the more
satisfying human attention right from
Jesus right to the female character okay
I identify with her that's the lie being
crucified I can write any practices
thought yes
I'm interested in the connection between
rupture and mysticism and thinking about
Judaism at this period and in Spain when
we have Kabbalistic traditions mm-hmm
which will eventually become traditions
in the post-exilic period but it's God
himself his body is broken
whose rupture in Kabbalistic tradition
to wonder how much that's an inversion
or if there's any connection with what's
going on in the Christian story where
it's the human instantiation of God
who's were mystified the believer the
human is broken and has to be redeemed
by
mr. patrician coming out of Judaism is
that God at the point of creation
there's a cosmic accident a rupture
no because the divine smirks are
scattered right most have to be do you
God brighter than one scepter one trying
to be Lisa sparks - right team thank you
for the comment and for the question in
terms of the influence of Jewish
mysticism directly there are they a
direction so if Jewish mysticism is
talking about rupture and God splitting
in the various parts and the devotees
needing to put that back together it is
in some ways the inverse of what I'm
saying that you would put it back to
there and and reform it rather than sort
of wallow in the brokenness Cynthia
Robinson has tried to and I think in
provocative and interesting ways to make
the argument that Castilian Christians
were familiar with tropes from Islamic
mysticism just sort of in the culture
and so what she sees is much more
discussion of Mary and light and Jesus
and then Mary and blood and Jesus there
are a variety people who have questioned
her proposal because she doesn't have a
text that she can say this group saw and
this group saw or a moment that she can
say that this sermon was certainly all
she can do is extrapolate a likely
common cultural interest in light for
the name of God in terms of
inverting the interest in reclaiming I
haven't heard anybody I haven't seen any
be ready about it I think that would be
really fascinating to find there are
various attempts to suggest that Jewish
mysticism is an Islamic miss ism is
important to on c'est tres tres I've
went onto the cross but nobody's really
been able to link earlier than that so I
think that's a very interesting thing
that I would like to think about but I
haven't seen anybody do that
so thank you for this really really
interesting talk I don't come close to
really knowing anything about this so I
apologize this question was naive Ursula
basic but maybe it's a build on what
Professor Lofton was asking about
anti-semitism I guess I'm kind of
wondering why they care so much about
Jews at all I mean not I'm saying that
they shouldn't I'm wondering what it
actually signifies that they do I mean
because on one level it's like well
they're medieval Catholics of course
they hate Jews but officially as I
understand that there are no Jews in
Spain at this time of course that's not
true and they probably also are aware of
that even if they can't quite admit it
but particularly given the connection
that you gestured at between this kind
of internal anxiety and an external
projection of natives ads Jews so I
guess I'm wondering what is it actually
what is there to be interpreted in fact
what they seem incredibly interested in
signifying juice despite the fact that
officially they're already yeah that's a
great question and there are two parts
than I answer one is where the Jews were
we're in the passion treatises you expel
the Jews and then within a year or two
you get very very very concerned about
first century Jews and how does that
happen so the Jews that were in this
early 16th century Spain were the Jesus
Jews in these treatises the reason that
isn't just a historical oh it's you know
a long time ago but we in our society
don't have to worry about that group
anymore is that even before the
expulsion of the Jew in some ways the
expulsion of the Jews was an answer to
the question of the concern over
converts so there had been pogroms in
1391 in the wake of which many jews had
converted in order to avoid violence or
in order to have access to certain
societal
functions then in mid 15th century some
anxiety over whether those conversions
were real started peeking and people
this is when purity blood statutes start
being promulgated that if you that
somehow if you had been Jewish in a
previous turn or previous generations in
your family had been Jewish then you
might have a tendency to be attracted to
Judaism and the expulsion was really a
concern that converts kept getting
reclaimed and so there all sorts of Pro
and anti convair so treatises sometimes
written by old Christians sometimes
written by converts in the 1462 1480s
that are raising the question of whether
a convert could really be a true convert
the Pope intervenes in this and says yes
baptism makes people Christian that's
what it does but in Spain they thought
baptism when forced was very
questionable and people might tend to go
back so if you expelled the Jews the
idea was then people will not have
anything to go back to but in these
first jet this first generation that
particular things I'm talking about
it was the people were expelled three
years ago so they still have a very
strong potent life in terms of my my
neighbor was Jewish three years ago and
now is not and that's what the
Inquisition was focused on so convert
conversos become the Jews of Inquisition
Spain
thank you I'm a medievalist but north of
Spanish expose anyway yeah but and also
slightly earlier so I'm interested in
English and French and Latin passion
narratives and especially lyrics and I
just wanted because you started off
really interesting talking about as a
pan-european trends could you see more
about what's what if it is distinctive
about what is happening as Spain why and
I also make so maybe come back to not
opening section if you like round have
we gone in a very special direction here
or can you disable I mean that there's
plenty to say I know but and I would
just like you to know that out because
as he has as if we were talking about
such particular
I think that what happened when the
tradition was imported at the late 15th
century when they they translated
Bonaventure in the early 1490s the death
of Saxony in 1502 when people started
thinking with that they were people
trained to think about marrying and so
they expanded her and she's there in the
tradition and a very crucial moment to
marry and they expand that to being half
of every chapter in the entire text but
they also shift her from being simply
someone who weeps to being a character
whom you aid in the narrative then there
are other characters that might be
people who weep Mary Magdalene or the
women of Jerusalem but Mary becomes I
mean it's it's annex logical extension
simply an extreme logical extension of
what's already there but it's being done
by people who are attuned to Mary as
particularly powerful because she had
aided them in the reconquest because she
had been primarily a miracle worker and
that's something I've never seen a text
from any other part of Europe that has
half of every chapter about Mary is that
as opposed to I'm just interested in the
fact that when cause Mary is very
important in 30 century
that's a no-no Baptists and there are
ways in which the you know so many of
these in elements are certified
obsession with Marion ISM but also
different kind of explosion of
vernacular moving in French
much earlier guess why I like this so
these these these element least factors
that you're pointing out
how they turn yeah an earlier version of
a talked way when I should I had to cut
out to get it a little shorter was
citing Marine Bolton's work on lives of
Christ and lands and Mary where she can
has 400 texts of editions of 400 sorry
of 100 works that survived from 13 to 15
15 century and we have say five from
Castile so the question is partly why
that wasn't there before
and that's being addressed by people
like Cynthia Robinson I'm looking at
what happens what changes about it when
it comes in and what I think happens is
it becomes particularly about Mary and
it becomes particularly about Jews being
violent towards Mary but do we see
anything similar whether visual or
textual culture of the Saints we see the
other kind of parallel ships is there a
third role previously held by
interesting so whether or not this
weather the Saints are part of the
exemplar idea of the passion tradition
itself that's a great question um no no
I'm trying to think so I've got funding
a couple of years ago and I went through
various portions various cities of
Casteel and took photos of the passion
altar pieces which hadn't existed
particularly before the last quarter of
the 15th century and the Saints are
rarely present in those I did not
however take pictures of every single
surviving altar piece because I was
particularly interested in photographing
the passion ones certainly the Saints
are displaced entirely in these from
their strong central focus from medieval
Spain what I'm trying to think of is
whether the visionary sermons by Hana
so when she is talking about all the
feasts in heaven there's all sorts of
ways that this is reflecting a certain
passion spirituality because Jesus is
still wounded in heaven and he's sort of
feeding the Saints and the angels from
his wounds very very literally pastries
come out of the hand wounds and
top-shelf liquor out of the side wound
of swimming but I don't think the Saints
are wounded so I I think it displaces
that tradition although but follow me
you were the one who was flayed as of
interest in that in the sense of the the
visualization of the gore but that's
that's the only one that I can think of
in terms of liturgy the the hours of the
nails is a little bit early is one of
the most interesting one it's 1460s
constants of the Castillo and she's sort
of voicing Mary praying passionately to
the nails as something that both rips
his body and helps in salvation other
liturgies from the early 16th century I
don't know of any record of those what
we have we have the first passion plays
so the mystery play tradition is late
14th the 15th century and much of the
rest of Europe and the first ones we
have her in the 1490s and one of them is
actually using about a quarter of Diego
San Pedro's poem out to set up the scene
and that would have been done in the
church liturgical II the thing that we
had from the 15th century is Corpus
Christi liturgies those were the popular
processions in the fifteenth century
this is where semana santa is so
interesting when it starts is because
it's it is extending a popular
procession tradition but it is moving it
into Passion much more specifically
thank you so much for that thought I
want to I'm fascinated by the concepts
of disembodied grief and the continuum
of emotional pain and physical pain and
I've got to know her metric exactly he
said it but grieving as Mary's have
emotional crucifixion mm-hmm
I'm not familiar with how the galenic
tradition gets picked up in late
medieval Spain but earth earlier in
Galen and earlier in tradition Greece
not only is a pain but it can actually
kill you oh you can die as a result of
grief is that there in the tradition and
if so does Mary ever die and how does
that how does that work
that's a great question are you talking
about love sickness being able to in the
sort of the physical remedies for love
sickness and I'm thinking I mean hmm
okay I have not seen that particular
version referenced Lorado who I worked
on from my first book was a galenic
physician he's actually famous for first
for the first pharmaceutical treatises
that were published in Castilian so I've
worked a lot with the galenic medicine
and I didn't I have not found in at
least in his works reference to grief as
being people with killing that's very
interesting and I need to to look look
that up more thoroughly um and then the
other part of the question sorry does
Mary ever die and these things I mean it
is well that's the what's the extent of
the pain that that causes to that that
it causes to her body
the what really really started this
whole project was
this how in the world somebody could be
asked to imagine Mary crowned crucified
dismembered because I've never seen that
piece before one of the reasons that I
wanted to go take all of the photos of
all of the altar pieces that survived
was to see if anybody had ever painted
it and they didn't or at least didn't
survive
so crucified virgin as a phrase
suggesting that it be imaginably
meditated on yes the work that that does
in shifting her from being a model for
compassion to the sort of a salvific
nature yes have I seen anybody claim
that she actually died no in part
because her agony afterwards continues
the process of deep grief and physical
grief
[Applause]
[Music]